[Music]
now the Public Accounts Committee this
week published their report into the
potential impact of leaving the EU
without a deal warning of chaos at the
country's ports the chair of that
committee is Labour's make hello and she
joins us now thank you very much for
being with us so what did your report
find them well we've been produced a t8
reports in the last year and there's a
common theme Sophie through those that
it's going to be very challenging to be
ready to leave the U on whatever terms
the civil service has been hampered by
having to work on three options deal a
deal with a transition period and no
deal and as we reach this end game or
the end game I don't know how many end
games we've been having you know at the
beginning of the eginning in one of the
end games we're gonna you know with only
three months to go there's certainly in
civil services own words it's a
suboptimal outcome that we'll see
especially if we crash out with no deals
so it's been a real challenge and also
hugely expensive some wasn't something
that's got lost in this the expense to
the taxpayer of preparing for three
options is immense and preparing just
the preparations for leaving well under
whatever grounds is expensive should the
government have done more preparations
for No Deal that's what the accusation
has been well actually I mean if you
look right back so when David Cameron
first triggered this he did not need to
set the referendum up so quickly without
any preparation for what that would mean
then matter either make a min and she
triggered article 50 very quickly I
voted against it partly on those very
practical grounds that you couldn't
deliver in time what you needed to do
and then she called a general election
to delay things further so they pushed
this false deadline on themselves and no
wonder we're in chaos now and what
should happen if Therese me I think we
expect loses the vote next week
well there's potentially several options
that could could arise from that I mean
I think that we're hearing her own side
she can't bring with her so she's got
she will have to bring them with her and
the DUP in order to get a majority and
that's looking unlikely for Tuesday but
even for the various options after that
very difficult to know how it will be
achieved I think it's really interesting
if you look at how the Conservative
Party has approached this you know the
David Cameron through what he thought
was red meat to The Brick City is right
at the beginning and Theresa May has
followed that through they will never be
satisfied some of those people and I
think some of them want to crash out
without a deal that I think all those
feeling as
check out whether they would say it is
leaving on w2 very terms which they
would say is better than the current e
well I don't think it I think if you
look at even the current deal which I
don't think is a good deal at least
there's a bit of management there
there's a transition period and there's
some opportunity to keep discussions
going with Europe and that's the key
thing if you just have a hard deadline
then all of those discussions come to
abrupt halt and Britain will not be
prepared and we have looked at this in
detail and let's be clear my committee
is a cross-party committee we've got a
range of different views on brexit our
eight reports have been unanimous
reports so what should happen then in
your view and we're talking about random
are we talking Norway style e a
so-called soft brexit what should happen
I wish it was as simple as that I think
what we will find that the deal goes
down pretty sure of that
then it's up to the ball falls back into
the Prime Minister's hands there are
various options as we know that there
could be no confidence vote so there
could be she could come back with some
better deal from Brussels though it's
very difficult to know what she could
achieve at this point what I'm really
clear about and I think Hilary Benz
amendment is a really important one is
that we need to rule out as a parliament
no deal at the same time there it's easy
just to rule out all the options that
you don't really like you've got to come
up with an option that even if you don't
think it's brilliant it's the least
worst scenario well would that be yeah
well I've been very clear that
personally this is speaking less than
from the committee more but that if we
can't reach a decision well first for
the executive is failed you know the
government can't deliver on what it set
out to deliver if Parliament then cannot
agree then I think we need to look back
to the public and that could be a
general election or it could be a second
referendum both of those are potentially
very divisive both of those will require
very tight questions and very clear
options we will be scrutinized both
major parties about exactly what that
offering will be and I think that but
then that means that would be the only
way out of an impasse if the government
can't deliver and if the Parliament
can't deliver then that would be the
only option you described yourself as a
reluctant supporter of a second
referendum at the same time you voted
remain your constituency it's very
happily remain that you voted against
the triggering of article 50 which led
to the whole press that said leave me
you some people would say I don't really
believe you were very reluctant at all
this is exactly what you wanted for well
I certainly didn't want to see us go
through chaos and I think there's a
there's two strands this that's my
absolute you know love for the EU and my
passionate is
- yes - I wanted to stay I'm passionate
about it during the referendum very
devastated by the result but we are
where we are now we've got to find a way
forward from where we are now and that
either means that both sides compromise
and we find some way for when the Prime
Minister has failed in delivering that
or if that is not going to happen
through the structures of our democracy
through Parliament and through the
government then it would have to go back
to the people but I think there is a I'm
not why I been reluctant is I am NOT
unaware of the huge risks of opening
this up again we had the gun tree
divided down the middle and it's not
clear that that would be less of a
divide if we went back so we need to be
clear it alone is basic so that course
and that's always a prospect but also
you know we could the result could go
the other way and then that will still
have a divide so the nations divided so
one I mean one I think I would say and
one of the reasons I'm moving in it very
much in this direction is that this is
now a different question we've got a
deal on the table though pilots like to
reject that next week and this is much
more detail than was in the original
referendum so it would have to be a
different question if we just go back to
repeat the referendum that would I think
counter it but I think this all throws
up that the referendum doesn't fit very
well with our model of government if we
were in Ireland where they do this all
the time because of their Constitution
they have a much clearer message so I
think the challenge will be whether it's
a general election or a second
referendum the people having a say that
people need know exactly what the
details are and that needs to be laid
out very clearly ok miquellee oh thank
you very much for coming on the show
this morning
[Music]
you